hey everyone
welcome
true simultaneity
navigating all layers
transcending paradox
it's very much like joseph and the coat
of many colors
like synthesis consciousness
chameleon consciousness
all 8 billion hermeneutics of truth
at once
true simultaneity
is the ability to fluidly navigate
all of these layers
like a jedi
effortless action
all 8 billion people are at different
stages
many are in egoic contracted
separate entity levels of consciousness
some are tasting oneness
on their journey of seeking and
finding piercing the veil self slash god
realizing
and very few have completely
pierced that veil and then have
recognized the true
dream like illusion-like
non-dual indescribable perfection
of the absolute of what this is
so how
can we unpack here
to be an absolute jedi
at navigating all these layers
well we'll start with non-duality
this is it
the closest we can describe it
like lao tzu said the eternal dao
the tao that can be named is not the
eternal dao
meaning every single time that you aim
to put
words around
what is non-duality they fall
short so
what we do is we do our best
to gently and lovingly
point to it
many different faces
and paths to the same one peak
in essence this is already whole
this is already absolute unconditional
love and freedom
this is completely perfect
this is a dream this is an illusion this
is a mystery
this is an appearance
a very childlike
innocent wonder ah
bliss piece
is the typical
measurement of one's non-duality
how present
in the simple now
are you
this eternal presence
and in very many ways the easiest way to
also describe it is saying some things
like
i thought i was a person then there was
nothing left
i've talked about this quite a bit on
the program
i used to be alan sakyon
then i was atlas
and now there's just no layers of
identity at all
zero none
not even the non-dual awareness
you transcend even the observer even the
witness
even that very i am-ness you transcend
even that
agentless attributeless
metaphysical zero
and now the simultaneity
kicks in quite a bit here because
well how does atlas navigate his
daily activities well
that exact way we do this concession
into the realm of duality
again this true simultaneity being key
so that when there
is a
inquiry hey atlas will you bring this
microphone over there
the responses yeah not a problem
so you can navigate all the layers
so you can drop into your quote name
you can drop into the quote
form
and into time
will you meet me at 3 pm
and also into paths
meaning with seeking and finding
there are actually optimal paths
up the faces of the mountain to the
one end and
the
classical spending 30 years
at a monastery is in very many ways over
there are many direct path teachings
that help people with very simple
pointing out that enables
people to
shed their layers of identity to
a non-dual awareness and then to
become even agentless and attributeless
this is why it's really
in the non-dual perspective it's
a joke and even called spiritual
lollipops
to separate things into seeking and
finding
as in the quote
there's nothing to seek or only those
who are truly ignorant seek what is
already there
as in the indescribable perfection is
already this
happening this appearing
this is it already unconditional
so only a fool would go on some
journey to seek and find something
so yet we recognize that
egoic levels of consciousness that are a
separate entity
are have this true
impulse this true desire which is
to dissolve the contracted sugar cube
of the separate entity ego
into the hot t of infinity
and so to deny that
is not simultaneity
true simultaneity is the ability to hold
the
absolute non-dual while simultaneously
acknowledging
the fact that there is a seeking
into finding in terms of piercing the
veil
egoic consciousness dissolving into the
hot tea
of infinity
and the more that we undergo this god or
self-realization
process this is the best service that we
can actually
render humanity so again as much as it's
a
dream and that it's an illusion and that
it's an appearance and we can just be
childlike wonder and bliss and awe
at the same time we recognize that
ego at consciousness in the
positions of greatest power across our
planet
is likely the most upstream malady
that we face so again can you hold both
yes dream yes illusion
yes while simultaneously holding
a go at consciousness and positions of
leadership is the greatest upstream
malady
and you got to be really careful to not
fall into the cycle of spiritual
lollipops in the sense of a continuous
process of incessant seeking
so there's a balance again between
optimal paths to pierce the veil to
self-realize
and an incessant amount of seeking
what you already have which is the
definition of ignorance
so the diamond necklace is already
around your neck yet
it is up to you to recognize it
and similarly these
this duality of suffering and well-being
is important to understand
again the non-dual perspective is that
everything's absolute
indescribable perfection and there is no
suffering there is no well-being
yet at the same time the dual
perspective of there is suffering and
there is well-being
we can simultaneously hold that this is
what truly makes us like joseph in the
code of many colors this is what makes
us truly like a chameleon
or like a synthesis level consciousness
so in this case it would be something
like
the recognition that
egoic levels of consciousness in the
positions of greatest leadership around
our planet is our most upstream malady
the recognition that that catalyzing
a lot of
valence or qualia of
suffering
is something that would be ideal to move
towards well-being
no matter how non-dual you are
in a sense to see one
person that's in severe
pain that's
crunched over in a ball weeping
on the ground due to severe physical
psychological pain and another person
that is blissed out and peaced out
standing right next to them
at one point in a non-dual perspective
this absolute dream and illusion
and in another perspective the dual
perspective it is
well let's do our best right now
to heal the physical and psychological
pain
of the person that is currently
experiencing that state of valence
state of qualia
because if that was you in that position
or me in that position
it would be great to have people that
cared to
help alleviate that valence
that qualia of suffering
as much as we can bask in the glory that
ah this is a complete illusion
at the same time it's great to have
the alleviation of that suffering
and this is where we can also get into
the trap of entrepreneurial lollipops
with civilizational architectures
as in i'm going to spend 80 hours a week
every single week on building the future
i'm gonna build the future of
decentralization infrastructures and
build the future of all the sustainable
energy build the future of all the
permaculture of farming
build the future of the artificial
general intelligence and the
bio and neuro technologies in the
virtual realities i spend all of my time
on that building
building building because i care about
eradicating suffering
maximizing well-being so you see how
there's also an entrepreneurial lollipop
there as well now if that's the way that
the wind moves
the realized
person then that's the way the wind
moves the realized person if that person
has
a ability to
have a deep amount of
eternal presence
as they the wind moves them
into that process then that's their
unique expression
of what this non-dual appearance is
yet if the entrepreneurial lollipop
again we're speaking in a really
beneficial way here we're talking about
like building the future of all of these
industries to maximize well-being
there are many levels of egoic
consciousness that have absolutely no
idea
what that is as in there are people with
a go at consciousness in positions of
power
that are solely trying to drive more
conspicuous consumption
their way greed materialism
and they have no idea what
the inward path is to recognize that
diamond necklace already around their
neck
so again
the key to true simultaneity
is to recognize that
there are
all these ways to navigate
the navigation is really the key to
simultaneity how much are you like a
chameleon
how much are you like a synthesis how
much can you
just be in
a state of non-duality
just being present with simply
this appearing yet
simultaneously can you recognize when
somebody is suffering
and can you not say ah it's just a dream
or an illusion
but can you literally go and help them
this is where even the dual
and the non-dual are again
transcended this paradox is transcended
by
just what is and that's ultimately what
non-duality is which is why duality is a
concession in many ways here
as a non-duality especially with the
tantric path
which means when you weave your
enlightenment realizations into the
social fabric
or the sahaja samadhi where you take
your enlightenment
and you carry it with you in all your
daily activities
this is in another way is the middle
path or the middle way
the goldilocks zone your ability
to effortless
action woo way as you pierce the veil
and self-realize which is why that
seeking impulse is in fact
very important
which is actually what enables you to
understand
at a deeper level in your essence these
non-dual teachings
somebody can point directly to the top
of the mountain
and you can skip all of these
layers and levels and paths
yet when you get there the idea of
the ego will be less dissolved
than somebody that has actually taken a
little bit more time
to go through the practice of dissolving
their ego
so we have to understand these types of
things
these types of understandings are really
helpful because they give us
a visualization
this has been really helpful also with
putting these different things that
we're talking about right now into
visuals which we'll be publishing
shortly
i'm looking forward to it because
they're really helpful again true
simultaneity
your ability to navigate effortlessly
the entire t of what this appearance is
again effortlessly it should make sense
that when somebody is seeking
for you to both say that
there's nothing to seek because you're
already it the diamond necklace is
already around your neck
yet also there are these optimal
strategies
for you to dissolve the egoic sugar cube
of the separate entity into the oceanic
infinitude
if you can respond that way to somebody
you are literally
at a very high level if you can
again know how to
respond fluidly
across different all eight billion
different
hermeneutics interpretations of the one
truth
from the ego all the way to the non-dual
and you know how to navigate that
flawlessly like joseph and the code of
many colors
again that's a really high level of
that eternal presence
do you completely recognize
the ability to both
be with the presence of the illusion of
the dream
while also recognizing when somebody is
suffering
and helping
true simultaneity is fascinating and is
for very advanced levels
the most advanced levels
and
the absolute surrender to the
effortless action that is unfolding
is the highest a complete
absolute surrender to the indescribable
perfection that this already is
and just
flowing with the dream
with the illusion on the crest
of the wave of that eternal present
where it's an effortless ability again
to navigate
an effortless ability
to navigate
when something with name is needed not a
problem when something
with time is needed not a problem when
something with form is needed
not a problem when something of helping
somebody and suffering is needed not a
problem
when your ability to
to point out non-duality
and the indescribable perfection of
simply this
not a problem
pointing out being agentless
no witness no observer
nobody here doing anything
not a problem
against true simultaneity it's gorgeous
it's absolutely gorgeous
thank you
let me know how you feel in the comments
love to hear from you
like the video subscribe if you haven't
share the video with people
that you know this would positively
impact
i love you thank you
true simultaneity
jedi like effortless
navigation
you